hello I'm vehement chandi a solution
manager for Education modernization with
Google cloud in the next few minutes
we'll talk about several important
Google cloud and open source tools that
can help make containerized development
easier and more productive
ready let's get started
[Music]
to set the context the development life
cycle can often be divided into two
parts and inner loop and an outer loop
the inner loop includes the work and
application developer does on their own
workstation including coding building
and testing locally this Loop repeats
many times until a developer is ready to
push their code to a source control
repository this is a typical day in the
life of an application developer the
outer loop on the other hand is where
all the developer's score is integrated
into one place built tested and deployed
code moves through different stages like
QA staging and production this is all
done on a CI on cicd infrastructure
today we are going to focus on the inner
loop and how several Google cloud and
open source products can be used to
speed up the containerized application
development process let's look at some
of the challenges with inner loop
development first there are security
concerns about user workstations
source code on a user workstation May
pose an exfiltration risk
a developer might lose their computer
and lose all of that work
additionally downloading test data is a
security risk for Enterprises
as such security teams limit access to
developer machines because they can't
guarantee their security
there are also logistical concerns
infrastructure administrators may be
worried about developer onboarding
delays if laptop shipping takes too long
particularly for remote employees as
Enterprises continue to expand globally
remote developers face unique challenges
virtual desktop infrastructure or vdi
may be slow and painful bills often take
too long offshore developers may not be
allowed to download code and remote
developers often wish their workstation
was on cloud so that they could access
it from wherever they want
building containerized applications is
still new to many Enterprises and we
have seen two broad approaches the teams
tend to take
in the first case Enterprises don't even
have the developers use containers When
developing on their workstations
they may deploy code and test it locally
but containers don't get built until you
reach the outer loop this leads to
scenarios where development doesn't
match production because it doesn't use
kubernetes
in the second case Enterprises may use
containers in the inner loop with Docker
but it may be slow and inefficient
process
after writing code compiling it and
testing the binary the developer will
need to build a container using a Docker
file push the image to registry and
deploy it all using Docker CLI
the developer has to switch back and
forth between the IDE and the docker CLI
tool can make the development process
particular really challenging for
developers who are new to Containers
many developers don't know how to debug
with containers it can take several
minutes for each change to be made
and the local environment still doesn't
match production because the developer
is not using kubernetes additional
container developer challenges include
how to debug issues in containers
how to test integration with other
microservices and figuring out who is
responsible for managing Docker files
and the different layers within them
luckily there are Google cloud and open
source tools that can help speed up the
inner loop for container Developers
first there is cloud shell editor
Cloud shell editor available at
ide.cloud.google.com is an online
development environment that makes it
easy for you to write code directly from
your web browser and deploy it to Cloud
next there is cloud code
is a set of IDE plugins that make it
easier to create deploy and integrate
applications with Google Cloud
it comes by default with Cloud shell
editor but can also be used with any
idea of your choice like vs code or
IntelliJ
Cloud code simplifies container
development workflows for kubernetes and
Cloud run allowing you to build deploy
and debug your application with just few
clicks
it also makes it easy to do step-by-step
debugging
the next important part is scaffold
an open source technology that helps you
hot reload your code changes to
Containers this means that every time
you make a code change the change is
directly pumped into a running container
this reduces the inner loop cycle time
from minutes to seconds since you don't
have to go through the time consuming
process of rebuilding and redeploying
your container
as per the runtime itself you can use
Google kubernetes engine or gke
editor and Cloud Core it's easy to write
code directly from your browser and
deploy it to gke even if you don't have
much experience with containers yourself
let's take a look at look at how the
ke in the Inner Loop would work
each developer can use their own
individual workstation perhaps Cloud
shell Editor to write their code
then they can deploy their application
into their own namespace on a shade GK
cluster as a part running in that
namespace
these parts running in developers
namespaces can easily connect to other
microservices as well
as and and also other Cloud products
like Cloud SQL and Pub sub
this makes it easy to do integration
testing with databases and other cloud
services much earlier in the development
cycle instead of waiting till outer loop
before discovering potential issues
let's take a close look at how you can
use this container development tools
together to deploy a hollow World
application to gke first visit
ide.cloud.google.com to launch Cloud
shell editor
I have some sample code on GitHub that
includes simple node.js hello world code
and the configuration files needed for
your interactive inner loop experience
first I'll clone this sample application
to open the cloned sample code as a new
workspace click on open Home workspace
[Music]
in index.js we have an application that
displays a basic greeting message to the
user
the most important configuration file in
this repository is scaffold.yaml
this file facilitates the build and
deployment of your application all
together in one go
note that the build section refers to
build using build packs and names the
images to be created
once the build and push is complete the
application will be deployed based on
the configuration in this deploy section
this section uses cue cuddle to deploy
and references a deployment.yaml file
this deployment.yaml file includes
configurations for a kubernetes service
and equivalence deployment
next
click the kubernetes engine icon in the
left navigation bar
this kubernetes Explorer makes
kubernetes development Easier by
simplifying cluster creation and
management
menu that appears click the plus sign
select the Google kubernetes engine then
you can select one of the available
clusters alternately you can create your
own new gke cluster
once you have selected a cluster click
run on kubernetes to build and apply
your application
detail locks this is a complete build
where the container image is built push
to the registry and then the application
is deployed on the kubernetes cluster
all with just one click
without scaffold you would have to
switch between the IDE and CLI and run
multiple commands to achieve this
[Music]
deploy process may take several minutes
we have speeded it upon purpose
once your app is successfully deployed
you can launch it via the link displayed
in your output panel
now let's make a code change
you can change the message in the
index.js you'll notice in the output
panel that the file changes are synced
immediately to the running container
it did not build and deploy the
application again which means the
scaffold saves several minutes for each
change
Cloud shell editor also has helpful
debugging capabilities
let's adjust the code and add a few
breakpoints
from the cloud code menu click debug on
kubernetes engine
once you see the orange bar at the
bottom you are now in debug mode
launch the application by hovering over
the URL link displayed in the output
panel like before and click open web
preview
foreign
which is now a red dot outlined in
yellow
if we open up the local variables
section we see that our message variable
starts out as undefined
but if you click the continue icon the
message variable changes as we moved on
the code in the file
once we get to the last break point we
can click continue to run through the
rest of the program since there are
there are no errors in this this results
in a functional web page
once you are done you can click the stop
button to stop your debugging session
are you interested in learning more
about the best practices for
containerized development as part of the
cloud application modernization program
or camp we have container developer
Workshop that you can take to learn
about inner loop best practices to
improve productivity and build
applications faster on kubernetes and
serverless if you'd like to take part in
this Workshop please contact sales using
the link in the description below and
make sure to watch other videos on our
camp Series where we cover an overview
of the camp program gke optimization and
modernizing Legacy applications thank
you so much looking forward to seeing
what you build with Google Cloud
[Music]